welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and black widow remains the first
feature film on marvel's phase 4 lineup
and despite repeated pandemic related
delays
hopefully the latest good news will mean
we'll actually be able to see this one
in theaters
i had assumed i speculated all i could
about this movie but then
boom a recent companion book to the film
revealed a major clue about how
black widow fills in mystery gaps in
ensuing history
other avengers who could cameo in it and
the mutant related reason marvel
initially chose black widow to kick off
phase four
that reason mutants mutants i kind of
jump the gun anyway spoiler warning
going forward in case any of this
theorizing ruins your life and this
video is brought to you by squarespace
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
okay so when we started examining black
widow promo footage one thing that
immediately jumped out at us is the fact
that this movie is partially set in
budapest and we know budapest is
important to natasha roanov's life story
based on a throwaway joke with hawkeye
in avengers
just like buddhism all over again you
and i remember budapest very differently
a joke that avengers endgame called back
a long way from budapest
what's additionally interesting about
seeing budapest in black widow is that
we have been told the movie takes place
between captain america civil war and
avengers infinity war
between 2016 and 2018 but that line in
avengers suggested some past budapest
event sometime before
2012 so we could be looking at
flashbacks or we could be looking at
a revisiting of that old place so really
the question marvel keeps posing to us
is
what happened in budapest but this
recent black widow book shed some light
on that mystery scarlett johansson was
quoted saying
we all agreed that we had to find out
what happened in budapest
we thought that if we didn't go back to
budapest to find out what really
happened there
people will feel unsatisfied i wondered
what did happen there natasha is haunted
by the fact that she has
his past that she feels so guilty about
unfinished business this is a guilt that
follows her around which all stems from
what happened in budapest black widow is
not about what happened to budapest
but it is a huge jumping off point for
us to
understand the heaviness of natasha's
burden
and even more interesting when this
quote made headlines hawkeye actor
jeremy renner jumped on instagram to
comment posting
hmm loose lips sink ships net
well baby hawkeye just gave us hope for
an avengers cameo
don't shut up you started this so we are
learning that budapest isn't just an
event natasha remembers differently
it's the source of her guilt and her
unfinished business
the red on her ledger and i think that
we can infer from that endgame moment
that being
a long way from budapest is a place
natasha is happy
and relieved to be in when it comes to
this unfinished business in budapest
it's worth asking how could anything
compare to what they were going through
in this moment
i believe that he and natasha had
previously faced
enhanced non-human beings in the heat of
battle
and the way i see it there are two
options for who those enemies were first
explanation
skrulls budapest could have been an
early front in the secret invasion a
three-way war between earth and the cree
and the scroll
clint's joke could have just been well
here we are fighting nasty looking
aliens again
and i mention this explanation because
with captain marvel and the ending of
spider-man far from home yeah marvel is
definitely prime in the thumbs for a
secret invasion storyline at some point
soon but i think the more important part
of that budapest exchange in avengers
was natasha's reply
for her budapest was not a fun escapade
of piling up enemy combatants like in
two towers
it was a dark haunting experience with
unfinished business this black widow
movie will revisit so i have a second
theory for what this is
really about but before we move on
thanks again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
are you looking for a website to sell
your wares say you've got the world's
best
thirst trap david harbor art and the
world just hasn't seen it yet well you
can present your work using
squarespace's professional portfolio
designs you can display
projects in customizable galleries and
add password protected pages to share
private work with clients which we know
is just david harper he just wants some
beautiful renderings of his own bod
with squarespace you can auto post your
content to twitter facebook tumblr you
can also easily
import from instagram twitter other
platforms to give your site the personal
visual flair that you want squarespace
will even sell you a url
now i'm not sure if isdavidharber
ericbossfather.com
is available but if it is squarespace
will sell it to you
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you are ready to launch
go to our custom url in the description
to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain okay so when we ask
what happened in budapest what kind of
enhancement would natasha
feel so disgusted with herself for
killing how about
mutants yes natasha romanov must have
had some
experience with enhanced beans in the
field she doesn't bat an eye when she
meets people like bruce banner
steve rogers thor actually nick fury
selected
natasha in particular to track down and
recruit
the hulk bruce banner she's got away
with people like this
natasha more than any of fury's assets
was his top expert
at hunting down loners with special
abilities how did she
get to that point i ask you the little
we've seen of natasha's past came to us
in avengers age of ultron when wanda
maximoff a gifted sokobian recently
revealed by marvel to possess the mutant
x
gene cursed natasha with the memory of
natasha's red room training
that imagery hinted that natasha was
programmed by the red room
to see defenseless victims as targets
and in the black widow movie promo
footage various shots of
other red room assassins suggest that
they too
have been programmed as super soldiers
who kill without
empathy i believe wanda's deep dark
secret her unique training for various
exploits around the world in budapest
but also other past
tragic missions that have been brought
up throughout the mcu from loki
mentioning a sao paulo incident in
avengers
can you wipe out that much red drakov's
daughter
sao paulo the hospital fire natasha
story decap about extracting an
iranian nuclear physicist and winter
soldier five years ago i was escorting a
nuclear engineer out of iran
somebody shot out my tires near odessa
we lost control
went straight over a cliff i pulled us
out all of this
is natasha's past history as a hunter of
mutants
when government forces want to get their
hands on some enhanced human whether one
created by post-birth experimentation as
we've seen
or one born with it as we're about to
see a lot more of
runaway mutants they deploy mutant
hunter black widow tasha romanov who
drags these bounties back
in but ever since joining the avengers
every one of those names continued to
haunt natasha her unfinished business
is the mutants still locked away
undergoing cruel experimentation
one of those facilities could be that
siberian prison that alexis shustakov
breaks out of
and the other inmates there may be
future x-men like peter rasputin
colossus
other mutant conflicts over the years
could have taken place in iran
in sao paulo and yes in budapest
the pre-2012 episode where clint and
natasha first met
unfinished business that could have led
to innocent mutants being locked up the
red and natasha's ledger is
the list of names of detained mutants
perhaps this black widow film will show
us hawkeye jeremy renner in this
budapest flashback to establish
natasha's guilt over rounding up those
mutants helping clint and helping other
black widow agents all
to set up her new mission in this movie
to return to budapest and to free
those mutants giving her a vital final
mission in the mcu
to expand this universe in ways that
will outlive her
tragic sacrifice what do you think
happened in budapest you can discuss
these theories with me on our official
discord server by becoming a patreon at
patreon.comrockstars and to get some
great apparel and accessories is to
check out our merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com subscribe to
rockstars follow me at ea boss follow me
rockstar see you next time
boom
[Music]
you